[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: And it gives
me great pleasure
to introduce our
speaker, Edna McNulty.
[APPLAUSE]
ENDA MCNULTY: How we doing?
AUDIENCE: Good.
ENDA MCNULTY:
Hands up if you are
incredibly excited about
this session over the next 50
minutes or so.
Love your style.
This man was here
15 minutes early.
Hands up who doesn't really
know what to experience.
You're going, what the
hell is this all about?
So how many of you would
say you just don't really
know what to expect?
Hands up nice and high.
Please expect fun.
Please expect a lot of energy.
Please expect a
lot of interaction.
And please expect to be
inspired about your potential.
Is that fair enough?
I'm going to give you
a little snapshot,
just for about 10 seconds, and
then going to get everybody
in this room rocking.
The snapshot is, I'm trying
to fit into about 40 minutes
now what I've
learned in 25 years.
I find that a massive challenge.
So I'm incredibly excited, but
yet I feel hugely challenged.
Can I ask you to put your
books or your laptops
underneath your chairs please--
your mobile phones, your
handbags, or your man bags?
And you're going to do
the following for me.
Can I ask you in
the next 60 seconds
to meet all the Googlers.
Shake their hand, and tell
them, what's your name,
and what do you
currently do for Google?
That is including everybody,
even the guys and girls in AV
and even the guys and girls
in McNulty Performance.
You've got 60 seconds
to do it, which
means you must do it with
high energy and a lot of fun.
Let's roll.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
ENDA MCNULTY: Loved the energy.
Absolutely loved that energy.
The person sitting
alongside you,
give them a little bit of a
nudge with your elbow for me,
please.
Give them a little
bit of a nudge.
Can we have about 40 minutes
with no ego, is that OK?
I don't really care if
you've got a degree.
I don't care if
you've got a PhD.
I don't care if you've got
a master's or two master's.
I don't really care.
I know nothing about Google.
So I'm not going to claim
that I know anything of Google
like I claim to say
I know A, or B, or C.
I know zero about Google.
Is that OK?
So I'm not going to tell
you how to do your jobs.
I'm not going to tell you
how to do anything better,
because I don't know anything.
So I don't have the
arrogance to tell you
how to do anything better.
Is that fair enough?
And just for a bit of fun, it's
a pretty big rugby weekend--
just for a bit of
fun, we're going
to list a few little exercises
if that's OK with everybody.
If I say tackle, I need
you up on your feet
in a rugby tackle position.
Is that OK?
That's going to look a
little bit like this.
You're going to stand up quickly
with your hands up in the air,
ready to tackle.
Is that fair?
Let's try that out.
I want a side effect to that.
I'm going to call
you South Africa.
I'm going to call you Ireland.
Is that OK?
Let's start off
with South Africa.
Tackle!
Average.
Take a seat.
OK, I'm going to
call you guys out,
and I want a real good passion.
I want really good aggression.
I want really good
side effects, OK?
Tackle!
[COLLECTIVE ROAR]
Who's going to win this game?
OK.
Ready to go?
So give me a bit
more sound, please,
in this microphone in the
back there, gentlemen,
if that's all righty.
And this group
here, please when I
say "tackle," I need you
bringing your best energy.
Tackle.
[COLLECTIVE ROAR]
You were weak.
OK, Ireland, do not
give into these guys.
Please do not give in.
Tackle.
[COLLECTIVE ROAR]
No brainer.
If I say run-- and
by the way, this
is going to include
all the girls and guys
on the right-hand side as well.
If I say run, I need
you to run faster
than your competitor on your
left, your right-hand side
with your feet on the floor.
Like so.
OK, go!
Faster, opus.
Stop.
If I say engage, I need you
to put your arms very quickly
around the guy or
the girl on your left
or your right-hand side.
Engage.
Tackle!
[COLLECTIVE ROAR]
Run.
Cut.
Pretty good.
At any station in
this session, if I
use any of those
little clues, I'm
going to ask you to
move pretty quickly.
Is that OK?
On a serious note,
how many of you
think that seminars
or the way we
educate people is actually dead?
That we now need to stimulate
in a different way--
we need to engage
in a different way.
And we need to make it fun.
We need to make it entertaining.
And we need to make it
incredibly stimulating.
If you strongly agree with
that, please scream yes
in your native language.
That is if you're
Irish, say it in Irish.
If you're French, say in French.
If you're Spanish,
say it in Spanish.
And so on.
If you strongly agree
with that comment,
please scream yes
in your language.
Go.
[AFFIRMATIVE RESPONSE IN UNISON]
I love to hear tá
shouted very loud.
For those of you not Irish,
tá is "yes" in Irish.
I know you're all incredibly
fluent Irish speakers.
I know there actually is some
people in the audience who
are fluent Irish speakers.
Tackle!
[COLLECTIVE ROAR]
OK.
This session is not
focused on Google.
I hope that you take it
as a little gift to you.
Maybe it's a good
time of the year
to start to reflect
on your potential.
And the session
is 100% orientated
towards your potential.
We're going to cover about
three or four key things--
one, your mindset.
I 100% believe if you
have the right mindset,
then you can unlock
your potential,
whether it's in your
sporting life, your business
life, your personal life.
Two, we're going to
talk about your energy.
We believe firmly
that whether you
are in these sort of scenarios
or whether you're in Google,
your energy is
absolutely everything.
And lastly, we're going to talk
a little bit about your mission
and your goals.
We refer to mission
like goals on steroids,
as if you're injecting
steroids into your arms,
and you're going to chase hard
after your goals as a mom,
as a dad, as a husband, as a
wife, or maybe as an employee.
Tackle.
[COLLECTIVE ROAR]
The session-- I guess--
you are in the right place.
It's OK.
You are in the right place.
I hope it's OK with you guys.
I would say a lot of you
in your Google life--
maybe in your business life or
maybe even in your family life,
feel a little bit like this.
You're going, how am I
going to possibly balance?
I've just bought a house
or an apartment in Dublin.
I've just got a
team of 25 people.
I'm managing 200 people
in total across Europe.
I'm under major pressure.
I'm expecting to hit these
sales numbers continually.
And the more sales
I hit, what happens?
Ladies and gentlemen in the
sales role, the more sales
you hit, what happens?
AUDIENCE: Higher targets.
ENDA MCNULTY: Higher targets.
And then what happens?
Higher targets.
And the higher the targets, the
more we feel like, holy shit.
How am I going to stay on this?
And then you're thinking,
what about my family?
And what about my friends that
I haven't had a glass of wine
with for the last six months--
and one of them my
really, really best friend
that I haven't even met
for the last 12 months.
So very often, the busier
we get, the more successful
we get, the more we
climb that ladder,
the more it starts to feel
more like a tight rope rather
than a ladder.
If you can relate
to that, please
can I ask you to scream
"yes" in your language.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Tá.
ENDA MCNULTY: Now, we've
got a bit of a lower tone.
Now, you realize this
session will be a lot of fun,
but also a bit of
a serious side.
If I say to change
seats by the way,
I'm very wary of the people
on my right-hand side.
I want you to change
seats very quickly.
The person who's the
slowest to change seats
will have a pushups penalty.
OK?
Please be [INAUDIBLE] conscious.
Pushups penalty means you're
going to be up here doing
at least 10 pushups.
Change!
OK.
So one of the things--
in talking to Carly in
advance to this session--
Carly, thank you very much
for the work you're doing.
I turned to Carly and she talked
about one of the big things
she'd like us to refer
to is confidence.
I left the Irish rugby camp last
night at 12:30 in Carton House
after spending about 4 and
1/2 hours in back-to-back one
on ones with some of the Irish
international rugby players.
Then, we had a
management meeting
talking about the game,
obviously, the weekend.
Would you believe a lot
of the international stars
would come to me on a
regular basis and say, Enda,
I'm not confident.
Please, can you help
me in my confidence.
But yet in the corporate
world, we very, very seldomly
get gentlemen to come
to us to say they
need work on their confidence.
Women will come to us
a lot more regularly.
They knock on the
door and say, listen,
I don't have enough
confidence as a manager.
I actually am not confident
enough now in my current role.
I don't know if
I'm confident I can
continue to grow in this
organization-- and so on.
So in this session,
hopefully, we'll
give you a snapshot into how
you can improve your confidence.
But I would like you to think
about-- imagine that everybody
in this room for the next
12 months fully committed
to your potential.
What would be the
impact personally?
impact in terms
of your professional life?
What would be the impact
in terms of your friends?
What would be the impact in
terms of getting the most out
of your life, even getting
the most out of your weekends?
Would you agree
with me that if you
did that, you'd
have dramatic impact
on all aspects of your life?
Would you strongly
agree with that?
Just raise your hands and
clap your hands vigorously
if you agree with that.
Go.
[CLAPPING]
Faster, faster, faster,
faster, faster, faster, faster,
faster, faster.
Cut!
So that's what we're about.
We're about helping you
unlock your potential.
And again, I don't know about
you ladies and gentlemen,
but I would guess that if you're
here, by this time next year,
you're going to
have to go to here.
If you're a bit more
experienced and you
feel like you're here,
by this time next year,
you're going to
have to go to there.
And maybe if you're here
and you think you've arrived
or you've started to arrive,
I bet you you'll probably
have to go back to that--
whether it's you're just
about to have your first
child, whether it's you're just
about to change role, whether
it's you're going to say,
I really need to
look after my body.
I really need to look
after my body now.
I'm up here in terms of where
I am in my professional life,
but I'm down here in terms
of my physical fitness
and well-being.
If you can relate
to that, can I ask
you to jump up and
clap at the same time.
Go.
[CLAPPING]
Excellent.
Take a seat quickly!
So in terms of mindset,
we're going to give you
a quick masterclass in mindset.
And rather than me talking
at you and preaching at you,
let's do the opposite.
I'm going to ask you
in groups of twos
with the guy or the girl
sitting alongside you,
just discuss three
things for me, please.
Number one, how would you
rate your mindset out of 10?
10 out of 10 is the best
it possibly could be.
9 out of 10 is your mindset
actually is holding you
back significantly.
We actually call that
mindset sabotage.
OK?
Number two, please
talk about someone
who inspires you in life
in terms of mindset,
whether that's an amazing
female actress, whether that's
your mother, whether that
is perhaps your girlfriend,
or whatever.
Please talk about
somebody who inspires you
in mindset, number two.
And the last thing I want you
to speak about very quickly
is, what's the
single biggest thing
holding your mindset back.
You must discuss all
that in about 60 seconds.
So please, go to work.
Go.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
ENDA MCNULTY: Really, really
love your energy, guys.
Love your energy,
love your enthusiasm.
Have any of you ever heard
something in the last five
or 10 or 15 years, and you can
remember almost every word that
was said?
And for some reason, that
impact or that session,
or that experience had a
very inspirational impact
on your life?
Hands up if you can relate
to that over the last five,
or 10, or 15 years, please.
Well, let's imagine that if this
session was like that for you
and your personal life
or your professional life
in the next five or 10 or 15
years, that will mean everybody
would need to be incredibly
tuned and incredibly,
let's say, engaged from
an energy point of view.
Is that OK to ask?
So we're going to
run pretty fast,
but then we're going
to slow it right down
and, hopefully, make
an impact on you
in terms of your potential.
I wonder if you were to
think about mindset--
will you think about
something challenging
in your personal life,
would you say it's something
challenging at work?
Or where would you start?
I'm going to start by
telling your story.
I'm from Northern Ireland,
just across the border.
I'm about probably five
miles across the border
into Northern Ireland,
brought up there, obviously
my whole life.
And then, eventually, I
moved into Dublin here
about 10 years ago.
And when I was a
child, for some reason
I was stunned brushing my
teeth at the bathroom window,
looking into the mirror,
brushing my teeth--
nice and calm, nice and
relaxed as a little boy.
And for some reason, I got
the sense in my stomach, shit,
there's something
not right here.
Don't know why.
But almost a second sense
or this sixth sense--
something not right.
And as I was brushing my teeth,
next thing [SMACK] The window
that I was brushing
my teeth into--
and the mirror smashed
all over my face.
And I can remember
having glass under my--
and going, what the hell
is out there happening?
It was a bomb attack.
The Irish Republican Army had
planted a bomb beside my house
at home and blew the
windows into smithereens
and the glass literally
was in my mouth.
And I was taking
the toothbrush out
of my mouth, spitting into the
sink, with blood in the sink--
what the hell is
out there happening?
This is actually
the image of what
happened that particular day.
The Irish Republican Army
had killed British soldiers.
We won't be getting
into politics.
Don't worry.
But that particular day,
they killed British soldiers
just very close to
my house and home--
and a really, really
bad bomb attack.
But that's not the
important part.
The important part is, I walked
into the corridor of the home.
We have a big, long corridor--
a bit like the corridor
through the middle of
where you guys are sitting.
And I walked in and next thing,
I can hear my little sister
Emer screaming, Sarah!
My older sister had
already left for school
and had been outside the house.
Screaming, Sarah!
Screaming.
She was inconsolable--
screaming, and shouting,
and ranting, and raving.
And next thing, Sarah ran back
towards the house-- thankfully,
Sarah was OK--
ran back towards the house.
But all I can remember
was her lower legs--
blood running down
her lower legs.
For whatever reason, the
shrapnel from the bomb
had hit her lower legs, and
she had a little bit of blood
on our lower legs.
I remember my mother.
My mother was in the house,
and she remained ice cool--
completely calm,
completely resilient,
completely compassionate,
completely caring.
Everybody else in the house
was going crazy, frantic--
what's going on?
What's happening?
The windows were shattered
in around the house.
Everybody in the
house-- my father,
my sisters, my
brothers-- all gone
frantic-- screaming
and worrying.
She literally never
blinked her eyes--
ice cool, resilient,
caring, and compassionate.
She says, get a seat
in the living room.
The living room is a small room
in the middle of the house.
The window wasn't broken.
Sit down there on the couch.
She went and offered me a tea.
She brought the tea in as
if was any other Sunday.
any Irish mummy would do--
brought the tea in,
and sat us all around,
and said, calm down.
It's OK.
Calm down.
Put the TV on in the
background to see
if there was anything starting
to come through on the news
flash, or whatever it was.
That was well before
CNN and Sky Sports.
Sat us all down, 15 minutes
later, she says to me--
and I'll never forget it--
Enda, have you got
football during the day?
Yeah.
Mommy, yeah, yeah.
Go and get your bag.
What do you mean get my bag?
Well, I'm not going--
You're going to school.
Get your gag.
So she says, and go and
get your football bag.
Go and get your schoolbag.
Your father's going
to take you to school.
So my father drove us to school.
And that day, at
about 3:30, we were
training for football
like any other day.
My mother in that
little instance--
it was only probably
three to four minutes--
gave us a lifelong
lesson in how resilient
we can train ourselves
to become in adversity--
on how the impact
of your mindset
can impact everything
in your life,
even in a very
difficult, challenging,
adverse environment.
The vast majority of
people aren't even
tapping into a tenth
of a resilience
and a tenth of a kid belief
from a mindset point of view.
So that little
story, even though it
was a very short,
little occurrence,
inspired me for the
rest of my life.
My mother still is very healthy.
She's still an incredible woman.
And she still inspires me
and the local community
in terms of their potential.
She was a teacher.
She spent 35 years of her
life teaching young kids--
whether it was in English
language or English literature.
But most importantly,
I think she
was a teacher of how you
unlock your potential.
So I'm going to
devote and dedicate
this session to my mother.
Please stay tuned.
Tackle.
[COLLECTIVE ROAR]
Ireland are much sharper than
South Africa, very clearly.
Engage.
OK.
So you might say, but Enda,
that's a really grinding story.
I wanted to grind you in that.
Let's make it a
bit more positive.
This is a picture of
my friend [INAUDIBLE]
who's featured very firmly
in the book "Commit."
He spent 25 years in New
York City as a fireman.
I know a lot of you are in
leadership and management
roles, and I've been inspired
by a lot of leaders and managers
in business.
But to be honest with
you, ladies and gentlemen,
I have never met
anybody who's even
close to this gentleman
in terms of leading
and inspiring--
never even close.
He learned his trade in
the Bronx in New York City.
If you're in the
Bronx and you're
ahead and downtown in an
unbelievable, cohesive unit
in a fire engine, and you're
heading downtown expecting
to come across really
big challenges,
you're going to learn
leadership and pretty quickly.
In my Gaelic
football career, I'm
lucky to have been coached
by him for about five years.
He treated everybody equally.
He challenged us every
day to be at our best.
He challenged us every day
to bring our best energy
and bring our A-game.
He challenged us to be
better leaders, and better
footballers, or a better men
as well as better [INAUDIBLE]
and [INAUDIBLE].
How many of you think that
if you had somebody like that
in your life, it would
significantly allow
you to unlock your potential?
Pretty important.
If you're in a leadership
role, that's your role.
Your role is to help other
people unlock their potential.
Your role is to help
inspire other people.
I don't mean at an
offsite once a year.
I know Google do offsites
better than anybody.
And I don't mean
at a Google talk.
I mean on an ongoing basis,
your role is to inspire people.
[INAUDIBLE] is now
76 years of age.
He is still winning medals.
Billy from County [INAUDIBLE]
is 84 years of age.
He's still winning medals.
These guys' mindset
is incredible--
always growing, always
learning, always stretching
the boundaries, always
thinking-- can they get fitter,
can they improve, can
they improve their brain,
can they improve their body.
What about you guys
in the audience?
Do you think you can improve?
Because I would bet you
everybody in this audience
in the next 12 months, whether
you're 30, whether you're 25,
whether you're 40,
whether you're 45,
we're going to have a
lot of mountains ahead.
Whether it's
mountains in our jobs,
whether it's mountains
in our personal lives,
whether it's mountains in
terms or financial scenarios,
whether it's
mountains physically,
we're going to be encountering
those in the next 12, 24 months
and beyond.
The research says we're
going to meet adversely
about every seven weeks.
We normally say you're
going to meet adversity
about every seven days.
Let's give you the
skills to know how
to deal with that adversity.
So if you think about what
is the definition of mindset,
in 30 seconds with the guy
or the girl on your left,
your right, define
what mindset means.
Go.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
ENDA MCNULTY: So no, this isn't
coming up for whatever reason
on the screen.
I want you all at the same
time as me to scream this out
in unison.
Is that OK?
Mindset is-- let me start here.
Here we go.
AUDIENCE: A set of beliefs
or a way of thinking
that determines one's behavior,
outlook, and mental attitude.
ENDA MCNULTY: That's a pretty
profound definition of mindset,
isn't it?
Think about the significance
of that in your life-- over 20,
30, 40, 50, 60 years.
If you get your
mindset right, imagine,
therefore you get
your beliefs right;
your thinking right;
therefore you get your behavior
right, your outlook right,
and your mental attitude right.
But let's flip that on its head.
What have you got wrong?
I don't want to talk about it.
Let's keep this session
really, really positive.
Let's keep it on getting
it very much right.
And please imagine this is that
classroom that my mother taught
in in Northern Ireland.
If you get your mindset
right, we get our--
AUDIENCE: Attitude.
ENDA MCNULTY: Get our
attitude right, we get our--
AUDIENCE: Behavior.
ENDA MCNULTY: Get your behavior
right, please all in unison,
we get our--
AUDIENCE: Actions.
ENDA MCNULTY: We get our
actions right, we get our--
AUDIENCE: Results.
ENDA MCNULTY: So most
companies focus on results most
of the time--
[INAUDIBLE] results,
sales results.
I'm bored.
What am I talking about mindset?
What about uncovering
somebody's mindset?
What about unlocking
their mindset
and therefore imagine the
results the team can achieve.
And thus, we move towards
a higher, and better,
and more consistent, and
more enduring performance.
But what about you?
Have you got a growth mindset?
Have you got a fixed mindset?
Growth mindset,
they're always curious.
They go meet different
people at Google every day
to learn from them.
They actually go
out of their way
to meeting people
that are completely
different than them--
not the same person
with the same background
in the same language and
the same preferences.
And fixed mindset--
I don't like feedback.
Fixed mindset, I
don't get coaching.
don't get mentoring.
Fixed mindset, I don't
go on those programs
the HR team is running.
Fixed mindset, I don't
use the gym here,
and I don't really like it.
Yeah, it's the
best gym in Dublin,
but I don't really like it.
And I don't use
the swimming pool.
It actually smells of chlorine.
It's a swimming pool.
OK, and I don't go to the
personal trainers here.
They're not very good.
I know them.
They're exceptional.
No, I don't need to get fit.
I'm fit enough.
A fixed mindset.
I want you just for a minute--
I'm going to put on music.
I'm not going to talk.
I want you to read
through these,
and I want you to read
through which one of those
is connected to you
and where you currently
are in terms of your mindset.
[SOFT MUSIC PLAYING]
Growth mindset-- when
getting feedback,
I recognize my weakness;
I know what to fix.
Fixed mindset--
this work is boring.
No one likes to do it.
Why are you giving me feedback?
Growth mindset-- talented peers.
I wonder how they did it.
Let me figure it out.
Can I go and meet them,
and learn from them
and, have a bottle
of beer with them?
Growth mindset/fixed
mindset-- that bitch.
How's she doing that?
OK?
Growth mindset-- desires.
I want to learn new things in
Google and outside of Google,
in my sport, in my personal
life, in my professional life.
And here, fixed mindset--
I stick to what I know.
I'm good at sales.
I'm good at management.
I'm not a good communicator.
My emotional intelligence isn't
good and never will be good.
Fixed mindset-- I bet you
everybody in the audience
can relate to
either here or here.
And the good news is, everyone
in the audience actually
sometimes is fixed and
sometimes we're growth.
The key is, when we
find ourselves here,
to drag ourselves very quickly
towards a growth mindset.
This is the most powerful
piece of technology anybody
has currently got
in this audience.
Does that makes sense?
I know your Google
phones are cool as hell.
I know your technologies
are cool as hell.
But this is far more powerful.
I'm very impressed.
Massive round all applause
for that gentleman please.
[APPLAUSE]
So believe it or not,
one of the things
we're doing in the Ireland
rugby setup at the moment--
I have lot of business teams
around the world and people
who are elite performers.
One of those is a
young lady from Spain,
who's an elite surgeon
on babies' eyes.
That's a pretty
significant role, isn't it?
And she spends a
huge amount of time
at the moment developing
her brain power--
developing her mindset,
developing her brain's muscle
so she can perform
much better operations
much more consistently
and much more accurately.
So I wonder how many of
you in the last 12 months
would say you've spent any
time training your brain.
That's a pretty important
muscle, isn't it?
So everybody goes,
I'm going to yoga.
I'm going to Zumba.
Or I'm going to Pilates.
Or I'm going at spinning.
Or I'm going to--
what else are yous
guys doing-- triathlon.
I'm doing the 5k at the weekend.
But how many of you are
actually training your brain?
In other words, training
your brain's ability
to deal with adversity
and to allow you to
unlock your potential.
Hands up nice in high.
Who's doing any brain
training whatsoever?
Absolutely amazing.
Massive round of applause
for those guys and girls.
[APPLAUSE]
You guys and girls have got
no more than five seconds
to get to the front of the room.
You're going to tell
everybody what you're doing.
Quickly, run to the
front of the room.
Yes now.
[MUSIC - COLDLAY, "ADVENTURE OF
A LIFETIME"]
So these guys and girls
have all got growth mindset.
Give them an incredible
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
So what's going to
happen is, you guys
are going to get these guys
to do a particular activity.
But you're going
to be South Africa,
and you're going to
be the Dublin team.
Is that far enough?
So can I have a little bit
of space in the middle?
You're South Africa.
And you guys are going
to get them doing almost
like that Icelandic
clap like that.
You're going to do it
in unison, and you're
going to do it in unison after.
And you guys are
going to be boxing.
And you guys are going to be
boxing in unison after them.
Does that make sense?
OK?
Ready?
You're clapping.
Away you go.
You're boxing.
Boxing.
[ICELANDIC CLAP]
Faster.
And the voice, and
the voice as well.
OK, stop!
Let's flip it around.
You guys are going
to box, and you guys
are going to do Icelandic clap.
Go!
Boxing.
Stop!
You guys are going
to do Icelandic clap,
and you guys are
going to do boxing.
Quickly go.
[ICELANDIC CLAP]
Stop!
Everybody in the room--
Icelandic clap.
One guy there is a bit
too cool for school.
Can I have you to stand up?
What's your first name?
Yeah.
Yeah, up here, come!
Good man, you're
too cool for school.
Up you come!
You're actually going
to lead the whole group.
Is that OK?
You're going to lead
the whole group.
OK, you're going to do the
Icelandic clap from here.
Everybody in the whole room--
AUDIENCE: Ready?
Go.
[ICELANDIC CLAP]
ENDA MCNULTY: Louder!
Louder!
Louder, louder, louder!
Excellent.
Take a seat quickly.
You've got three
seconds to get a seat,
otherwise you're going
to be doing pushups!
So in terms of
your mindset, guys,
I'm going to give you
what we call Sesame Street
simple feedback on mindset.
Number one, be open to
learn in the moment.
We always use that
phrase, if there's
somebody crazy in your work
place, go and meet them.
Go and spend time with them.
Meet them for a bottle of beer.
If there's so somebody crazy in
your community-- and by crazy,
I mean good crazy--
they're thinking in
your local community
about creating a global
business in the same way
as the founders of
Google were crazy.
If they weren't crazy,
Google would not exist.
All the major
corporations in the world
exist because
somebody inevitably
had a growth mindset.
Number one, be open to
learning in the moment.
Number two, we use the
word "hunt" for feedback.
Does that make sense?
The best people in all
performance crucibles are
seeking feedback constantly--
after every performance,
after every meeting,
after every sales call,
after everyone one on
one with their manager,
maybe after cooking dinner
for their children--
constantly seeking feedback.
And I'm using that
one as a funny one,
but maybe that's a more
important way of finding out
how you're doing at home, never
mind how you're doing at work.
How many of you can relate
to that one, please?
Seek and hunt for feedback,
coaching, and mentoring?
Hands up-- how many in
the audience have a coach?
That's not even a
third of the audience.
The rest of you are
basically telling me
you don't really
value your improvement
and your development.
How many of the
Irish rugby players
would it be acceptable
to say they don't have
a coach, or Novak Djokovic
not to have a coach,
or [INAUDIBLE] not to have a
coach, or maybe even someone
like Oprah not to have a coach.
What do you think?
Or Madonna not to
have a voice coach.
What do you think?
It's pretty important, isn't it?
AUDIENCE: It's different,
though, in a sporting
environment because you have so
many coaches available to you.
Whereas in the
corporate environment,
you have to seek
out that person.
And it's harder to
seek out that person
unless you go outside
your profession
and you have to pay
a lot for someone.
ENDA MCNULTY: Aislinn
Connolly is probably
one of the best camogie
players in Ireland.
Give her a big round
of applause, please.
So Aislinn is right.
It is easier in sports.
But guys, that's
exactly the point--
differentiate yourselves.
Go and get a coach.
I don't mean get
a coach in here.
But get a coach out of here.
But find a coach who's going
to help you [INAUDIBLE]..
You don't have to pay.
Find somebody on your
team who can coach you
and you can coach them.
Develop your coaching skills.
Upgrade your thinking.
Take risks and see
failure as necessary.
I guess that's one
of the big things
about your culture in general.
Do something once a week that
scares the life out of you.
We've actually been testing
you in this session.
Are you willing to do little
things that scare you,
and challenge you, and help
you grow your comfort zones?
And then, obviously, move
towards growth mindset?
Continuous reading--
even Warren Buffett
talks about five hours a day.
I know all you guys are doing
five hours a day of reading.
I know you are.
Absolutely.
Development and obviously
learning-- tackle.
[COLLECTIVE ROAR]
So what I want to
challenge you on is,
I'm going to challenge you
that in the next seven days,
everybody in the audience is
going to have an experiment.
One aspect of your experiment
is going to be a growth mindset.
So if your friend says to you,
let's go to salsa dancing,
you don't go-- no, no,
no, I haven't got time.
Go.
Or if your friends says,
let's start the gym next week,
and let's do a really
good six weeks between now
and Christmas--
yeah, I'm on for it.
Not, well, actually.
I'm working late this evening.
Let's say another one
of your friends says,
let's make sure we
do that Mark Pollock
5k run in the dark that's only
in about two or three weeks
time.
Let's do it for charity.
Let's do it with our friends.
And let's do with
some family members.
Right?
Say, I'm on for it.
Growth mindset.
I'm going to challenge
you in the next week
as well in every interaction
you have with your manager,
or with your boss, or
maybe with your team.
Say, can you give me feedback?
How did I do today?
Really important question.
I wouldn't talk
about the people who
are very fortunate to have
worked with over the last 20
years.
But I would say there's one
big thing they have in common.
They're constantly
looking for feedback--
the best of the best to them.
Whether it's the eye surgeon,
whether it's the elite
superstar soccer player, whether
it's the world-class golfer,
or maybe it's the young
superstar female teacher
who's incredible in getting
opportunities all over
the world to go and
teach other teachers--
they're constantly
seeking feedback.
So please, can we ask you
to start on that journey
in the next week?
Moving swiftly forward,
if this lands on green,
you guys will do jump jacks.
If it lands on red, you
guys are going to do boxing.
If it lands on yellow, you're
going to be doing squat jumps.
And if it lands on
blue, you're going
to do what I call
a "stork stance."
I want to test your balance.
Is that clear enough?
Yes, Mr. Waters, let's get
the music on, ready to go.
So whatever the color is, I'm
going to give you an exercise.
We all ready?
Orange-- everybody on your
feet, running on the spot.
Go quickly.
Faster!
Faster.
Take a seat quickly!
Good!
This one here I know
what it's going to be--
blue shadowboxing
with a partner.
Shadowboxing.
Go.
We're very fortunate that in
the last couple of months,
one of the companies
brought us to Costa Rica
to work with their
global leadership
team for a full week.
They said the global leadership
team was actually burned out.
And they wanted to spend a
full week rejuvenating them.
I bet you there's people
in this audience who
in the last year or two have
felt as if you're burned out.
I bet you some of you
know people in your teams
that are burned out.
I bet some of you know
people in your families
that have been burned out.
And in Costa Rica, we got the
most incredible inspiration
about energy and wellness.
I'm going to try and
get that across to you
in about three minutes.
It's Sesame Street simple.
In Costa Rica, they talk
about moving naturally.
Going to the gym once a
day isn't good enough.
We need to build movement into
our days-- our every days.
We need to be up and
moving constantly
if we want to live
long, healthy lives.
That is scientifically
proven, guys.
Whether you absolutely
believe in science
or you don't, that's
a different story.
That's related to your mindset.
We need to exercise every single
day, whether it's in the gym
or whether it's a run.
But we also need to move
every single day constantly--
number one.
Number two, and your food
at Google is incredible.
But the only problem
with being incredible
is you eat a lot of it--
eat incredibly
well, but eat less.
Don't fill your stomachs
up constantly-- number two.
Number three, sleep is the
number one silver bullet it
in your health
and your wellness.
Number one, how many of you
need to improve the quality
and the quantity of your sleep?
Hands up nice and high.
It's a corporate epidemic.
People are not
sleeping well enough.
It's a major, major issue.
By the way, your sleep is
related to how much you move
and, of course,
how well you eat.
Stress is a secret killer.
One of our colleagues
is a cardiac surgeon
who says the single
biggest issue
he has every single day in
performing surgery isn't food.
It isn't a lack of exercise,
or smoking, or alcohol.
It's people in the
corporate world who
are not dealing with stress.
If he can relate to
that, please can ask you
to have a big deep sigh for me.
[SIGHS]
It's a big issue.
And it's not Google's
responsibility.
It's your responsibility
to manage stress.
There's a lot of young guys
and girls in the audience.
And the guys and girls in
the audience not so young,
a bit like me, we need to
manage our own stress--
take 100% responsibility.
And then, alcohol--
I know you guys don't
drink at Google.
I don't need to talk
about that one obviously.
So I'm going to try
to actually give you
a quick masterclass into that.
Is that fair enough?
I had you doing the
boxing earlier on
and you were all sort of going
through the motions-- what's
all this about?
I'm going to show you what
happens if you actually
get yourself fully
engaged in your life
if you do all these
things incredibly well.
Can I ask you to do a
little gentle stretch?
Just roll your
shoulders forward.
We're going to go to Rocky now.
Roll your shoulders
forward, nice and gently,
and roll your shoulders back.
Head to the left and head to the
right, up towards the ceiling,
down towards your navel.
Can I ask you to
jog nice and gently
with your feet on the floor?
A bit faster.
Bit faster.
So where you're sitting,
can I ask you to be boxing
as you're sitting down?
Rocky?
Faster.
Just ease off for a second.
When you get on your feet, I
want you bringing your best
energy-- even
smiling when you're
boxing with your partners.
I want to you have
a bit more fun.
So for example, what's
your first name?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ENDA MCNULTY: Up you get.
Good man.
[INAUDIBLE],, is that
what you call it?
AUDIENCE: No, it's, [INAUDIBLE].
ENDA MCNULTY:
[INAUDIBLE],, OK, boxing.
Don't you worry.
You shouldn't be
slagging me at the start.
Slag me at the end.
OK, we're doing boxing.
You should be figuring that out.
You should be using
your intelligence
to figure that out.
OK, hands up.
OK, face everyone.
Hit number one.
When I say two, hit number two.
Has he ever boxed before?
AUDIENCE: No.
ENDA MCNULTY: You can
figure that out yourself.
OK. one, two.
One, two.
AUDIENCE: I do it like this.
ENDA MCNULTY: One, two.
One, two.
Duck.
Oh, oh.
OK.
Everybody's going
to do it, but you're
going to it about five
times faster than that.
Is that OK?
So get a partner quickly.
You're going to do
shadowboxing one and two.
Quickly.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
ENDA MCNULTY: I know
what you're saying.
You're too busy to
look after your energy.
I'll never forget 25 years
ago, almost to the day,
a teacher in Northern
Ireland, again,
stood up and said something in
an old basketball gym to all
the boys-- it was
a boys school--
in the audience.
And he said something that had a
profound impact on me for life.
And literally for
25 years, there's
not a week that's gone
by that I haven't trained
five, or six, or
seven, or eight,
or sometimes, if
I'm lucky, 12 times
a week when we're playing
at a very high level.
OK?
Not a single week.
[INAUDIBLE] very
significant injury--
[INAUDIBLE] shoulder, or
whatever injury I had.
OK?
But he said something that
had a profound impact on me
for the rest of the life.
He said, health is the
crown on well people's head
that nobody sees
other than the sick.
That's a pretty big
statement, isn't it.
Health is the crown
on well people's head
that nobody sees
other than the sick.
In other words, we don't really
appreciate it until it's gone--
until that cardiac surgeon says,
if you don't make big changes,
I'm going to have to operate.
Or until somebody
says, actually, you're
moving towards type 2 diabetes.
Or until the personal
trainer says,
your body fat is on the
[INAUDIBLE] territory
you're now creeping into 15%,
16%, 17,% 18% and beyond.
It's easier today to be happy
than at any stage in history.
Unfortunately, in Ireland-- and
you guys are based in Ireland--
we're really losing
the obesity epidemic.
We're losing it badly.
We don't need very
advanced technology.
All we need is simple
technology-- a skipping rope,
a cattle bell at home, a
bicycle to work in the morning,
a set of weighing
scales, great food.
We don't need a lot of really
cool, sexy equipment-- a set
of dumbbells, look at your
diary, plan out your month;
get your heart rate
checked on a regular basis;
use your smart technology, even
for motivation; eat good food;
measure yourself regularly;
and obviously use
wearable technology.
All that equipment you can
buy for about $150 max.
How many of you need to get much
more focused on that before we
move towards year
end and not even
waiting until we start
on January 1 or 2?
Hands up nice and high, please.
So I'm going to give you about
five top tips in this capacity
and the five top
tips are grounded
in the best practice in the
world in terms of longevity,
but also in terms of wellness.
Top tip one, you
need to eat well--
90% of the time.
Top tip two, you need to be
exercising five times a week
for a minimum of 35 minutes,
and you need to move constantly.
Top tip number three
is, your sleep--
as we say in
high-performance sport--
your sleep is the
secret silver bullet.
If you're not
getting your sleep,
it's going to impact all
other aspects of performance
and your health.
Top tip number four is very
much manage your stress.
I don't even need to
look at this anymore.
Manage your stress.
Shout at me.
Scream at me, please--
or whisper at me.
How can you manage
stress better?
Go.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ENDA MCNULTY: Meditation.
Who said meditation,
first of all?
This lady in the front.
Who was that first
person to say that?
AUDIENCE: Somebody over there.
ENDA MCNULTY: I'm going to
give you the credit anyway.
Somebody else over
here said meditation.
Who was that?
Good man.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
over there.
ENDA MCNULTY: Give it
to somebody at home.
Massive round of
applause, please.
[APPLAUSE]
Guys, meditation-- if there's
one particular ancient,
old ritual that I can stand
over with 100% certainty that it
works with 98% of people--
meditation.
How many of you do
meditation, please?
Brilliant.
Please keep doing it.
Please build it into
your everyday rituals.
For everybody else, please
get curious about it.
There's a little piece in
the book about meditation.
And finally, I know it's--
for all you Gen X and Gen Y--
it isn't so sexy and
cool to talk about--
but do watch your alcohol.
Don't be throwing those
shots in you all the time--
a few glasses of wine are
very good for your health,
but don't overdo it
for obvious reasons.
So as we draw to a close,
let's say in 2017 in November,
you're standing here and
you're thinking about what
does the future hold for you.
Are you going to get married?
Are you not going
to get married?
Are you're going
to have children?
Are you're not going
Are you going to stay in
Google for the next 10 years?
Are you going to go
start your own company?
Are you going to
be really healthy?
Or perhaps, are you not
so sure about your future?
Three of the big lessons
I would be giving
to you all in principles would
be, number one, your mindset
is going to be critical
as you go on this journey.
Make sure you've got
the right mindset.
It's a bit like having the
right equipment with you here
as you go on your journey.
Number two, if you if you
don't have the energy,
you're not going to
be able to climb--
nice and simple.
And you only have energy by
doing the physical exercise--
by eating well, by sleeping
well, by hydrating well,
and so on.
If you don't have the energy,
you don't have the capacity,
as we say it, to do work.
Whether that's work climbing
through the mountains,
or whether that's
work on relationships,
or whether that's work
on COs, or whether that's
work on your technology,
let's say, challenges--
you need energy to do work.
The more energy you
have, the more capacity.
you have to do work.
The less energy you
have, the less capacity
you have to do work.
I interviewed a girl
recently and she says,
I've got loads of energy.
I've got unbelievable
passion for the--
I said, you must
be fucking joking.
I can't see it.
[LAUGHTER]
Low energy, low
capacity to do work.
There's nobody in the
world who is not motivated.
They just haven't found
their purpose yet.
Does that make sense to you?
If you're not motivated,
there's nothing wrong with you.
You just haven't
found your purpose.
If you find your purpose,
you'll find passion,
and you'll find energy.
So your mission-- please
get your mission sorted
between now and year end.
Don't wait till New
Year's resolutions.
And please have your small, your
medium, and your big goals--
and I don't just mean
your Google goals.
What about your personal goals?
Maybe you had unbelievable
weekend away with your friends
in the Alps in March--
a once in a lifetime.
Maybe it is by this
time next year,
you're going to be promoted.
Maybe this time
next year, you're
going be in the best
physical shape of your life.
Don't say to me,
but Enda, I'm 35.
I can't get in shape.
Or I'm 45.
[INAUDIBLE] 76, and I will
still be training with him
at Christmastime,
[INAUDIBLE] get
in the best shape of his life.
Mindset over matter.
We're going to finish with fun.
And the winners of
this fun activity
are going to get
about five books
to bring home to family, or
friends, or for yourselves,
or work colleagues.
Is that fair enough?
Everybody on your feet quickly.
So first of all, you're going
to get in groups of fives,
but you must get your teams to
look like, sound like, and move
like a high-performance team.
It could be boxers, or rowers,
or swimmers, or cyclers,
but you must get them to move
like, sound like, be like,
and almost look like a
high-performance team.
In groups of sixes, go!
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
ENDA MCNULTY: I'm going to
watch one group at a time.
I'm going to pick the
three best groups.
And then, we're going to
pick the single best group.
Is that OK?
So if you guys can get down on
your [INAUDIBLE] just to watch
what's happening--
I don't know what the hell
is happening over here.
There's something really weird
and strange going on over here.
OK.
Please, can you call
the board of Alphabet?
there's something really
weird going on over here.
OK, go.
[COLLECTIVE ROAR]
AUDIENCE:
[SPORADIC GRUNTS AND YELLS]
ENDA MCNULTY: They
were obviously--
[APPLAUSE]
You guys were obviously
at [INAUDIBLE] last night.
OK, let's go over
to this group here.
Let's go!
GROUP: One, two, thee, Whoo!
AUDIENCE: Left!
AUDIENCE: Whoo!
AUDIENCE: Right!
Right!
[INAUDIBLE]
ENDA MCNULTY: Massive
round of applause, please.
I think that's an Irish
[INAUDIBLE] cycle team,
I think, is it?
OK, this group here please.
AUDIENCE: Three, two, one,
GROUP: Engage!
[SCREAMING AND GRUNTING]
AUDIENCE: Push!
[LAUGHTER]
ENDA MCNULTY: Massive
round of applause, please.
This group here.
[INAUDIBLE] is going to
pick the winner, by the way.
[INAUDIBLE] is going
to pick the winner.
OK, this group.
GROUP: Row, row,
row, row, row, row,
AUDIENCE: High
performance, go faster!
GROUP: Row, row, row.
ENDA MCNULTY: Massive
round of applause, please.
[APPLAUSE]
This group, here we go.
AUDIENCE: Ready?
GROUP: Row, row, row,
row, row, row, row.
ENDA MCNULTY: Clearly
out of sync over there.
I'm not even going to give
you a round of applause!
Next group please, quickly.
GROUP: Row, row, row,
ENDA MCNULTY:
Unbelievable originality.
OK, group in the back.
GROUP: Tackle!
Box!
Clap!
Tackle!
Box!
Clap!
Tackle!
Box!
Clap!
ENDA MCNULTY: Brilliant.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: Left, left,
left-right, left.
ENDA MCNULTY: And the group
over here in the corner.
These guys are [INAUDIBLE]
[CHEERS]
Massive round of
applause, please.
OK.
Grab a seat anywhere
quickly, guys.
We're going to close out,
I promise, in the next 60
seconds, or [INAUDIBLE]
will kick me out.
Well done.
So guys, what I
would say to you is,
imagine that, for the next
week, everybody in this room
made a commitment to
challenge yourself
on mindset continually.
Whether it's getting
feedback, whether it's
when you walking
to a meeting, go,
I'm going to try to be at
my best in this meeting.
Whether it's when you're
in the gym this evening,
you try and bring your
best energy in the gym,
rather than just in
another gym session.
Imagine the next week you only
seek to eat good, quality food,
and you only seek
to make sure you're
having lots of water on board--
obviously, even if
you're socializing.
Does that make sense?
So have your few drinks, but
drink lots of water as well.
Imagine the next
week that you make
sure that you start to think
about your long-term goals
for 2018, 2019
and beyond, right?
Imagine the next week you
challenge yourself vigorously
to go and get a coach.
I don't care whether you get
it internally or externally.
And finally in
the next week, you
create what I call a map-- a
massive action plan about how
to unlock your potential.
That's what "Commit"
is all about--
a massive action
plan about how you're
going to unlock the most
potential you can possibly
get out of yourselves.
Hands up how many
think that would
make a big impact on
your life in a week,
never mind in a month,
never mind in a year,
never mind in 10, 20, 30 years.
If you strongly agree, please
scream yes in your language.
[AFFIRMATIVE RESPONSE IN UNISON]
So my call to action is-- those
sales people in the audience
would know there must be
a strong call to action
at the end of every session.
In the next week,
can I ask you to take
a massive action in
terms of your mindset;
massive action in
terms of your energy,
and your fitness, and your
well-being; and massive action
in terms of actually have
a big, long-term goal,
and therefore a mission that
you're chasing hard after?
Because it's much easier
to motivate yourself
when you know what that is.
That is my simple
call to action.
We're going to finish
with 60 seconds.
We're going to blow this
bloody roof off in 60 seconds.
In the islands there,
push the chairs
in nice and tightly please.
OK, you're going to
get on your feet,
and you're going to shake every
single person in this room's
hand.
But you're going to do it
in a very creative way.
It could be a high five.
It could be a low five.
It could be jumping up
and double high five.
But you're must do it with
every single person in the room.
Bring your best energy, and
bring a little bit of fun,
a little bit of flair, and
a little bit of creativity.
You've got 60 seconds to raise
the roof off this building.
Go!
So just for a bit
of fun, we're going
to ask you to do about
five different poses.
Is that fair enough?
OK?
So pose number one--
serious, very
serious-- dull, boring.
OK.
Pose number two, you're
after winning the lottery.
[CHEERS]
Pose number three is
you're all boxers.
Pose number four,
you're Usain Bolt.
And pose number five,
whatever you want yourselves.
Thank you very much, guys
for coming along today.
[APPLAUSE]